- [Narrator] Airbnb will go public
with an estimated market
valuation of over $42 billion.
A remarkable feet when
considering just eight months ago,
the home-sharing giant was in crisis mode
with its business being crushed
by the Coronavirus pandemic.
From April to June, 2020,
revenue was down 72%
as travel and bookings came to a virtual
standstill worldwide.
Here's how Airbnb managed to
pivot towards profitability
during a global pandemic
and how it might fair
amongst continued travel
restrictions and beyond.
When the pandemic struck in March,
travel restrictions around the
world sent Airbnb's bookings
and revenues into free-fall.
Bookings in Europe alone went down 80%.
Airbnb was burning through its reserves
and needed a swift infusion of cash.
So its first lifeline was
securing $2 billion in loans,
but these didn't come cheap.
- So when the pandemic
hit, Airbnb was bleeding
through its cash reserves and
it needed a swift infusion
of cash.
But the loan that they got was,
came at a very steep interest rate
and it was an interest rate of 11%,
which is often associated
with distressed assets.
- [Narrator] At this
point, Airbnb's valuation
had fallen from $31 billion in 2017
to 18 billion in April, 2020.
Despite this, Airbnb
was still under pressure
to go public by year's end.
- So Airbnb CEO had toyed
with the idea of going public
for years, but he'd stopped
short of pulling the trigger.
Now that was leading to
some anxieties setting in
among early investors and
a handful of employees
who were set to lose their
stock options next year.
- [Narrator] Like many other
companies during the pandemic,
Airbnb dramatically
reduced its cost to get by,
costs that have grown significantly
over the last few years.
Before the pandemic, Airbnb had expanded
into new areas like
transportation and media
and spent big on things like marketing
and a new corporate headquarters,
increasing the company's total costs
more than five fold between 2015 and 2019.
- So even before the pandemic,
you had board members asking executives,
"Hey, why are your costs so high?"
Airbnb spent big to expand
into all sorts of new areas.
It also spent big on a
new corporate headquarters
and it typically spends heavily on things
like sales and marketing.
- [Narrator] To alleviate
its balance sheets,
Airbnb cut big expenses, put
many non-corporate projects
on hold and laid off a
quarter of its staff.
- They early on said that their founders
wouldn't take a salary.
They cut pay in half for top executives.
They slashed sales and marketing expenses,
but it still wasn't enough.
We spoke to CEO, Brian Chesky,
and he said he went through
his accounts line by line
to see what could be cut.
- [Narrator] But none
of Airbnb's maneuvers
would work if people didn't start booking
on its platform again.
So the third move it made
was to adapt its platform
for pandemic travel.
- People were sitting at home.
They still wanted to travel
but they couldn't get
onto a flight.
So what people start doing
is that they start driving
to smaller towns and cities.
And what do they do?
They book Airbnbs because big hotel chains
don't have a footprint there.
So Airbnb gets lucky.
- [Narrator] Before the pandemic,
big cities visited by tourists
had been Airbnb's strength,
but these new local stays
in primarily suburban
and rural locations became
the company's focus.
- CEO Brian Chesky sees this trend
and immediately capitalizes on it.
- [Narrator] The company
redesigned its website and its app.
So its algorithm would
show prospective travelers,
everything from cabins
to lavish beach houses
near where they lived.
By August more than half
of bookings were made
for stays within 300
miles of guests location,
according to the company.
And these moves help stem
the losses in reservations.
The company reported a surprise
profit in the third quarter.
This quarter is typically
the most lucrative
for the company and
Airbnb has turned a profit
in that period every year since 2017.
Airbnb has never had a full year profit,
but it's turned around
during the global pandemic,
and at a time when the
hotel industry is drowning,
has gooey investors confidence
and helped its valuation bounce back.
- One of Airbnb's near term challenges
is of course the pandemic.
What will that look like in the future?
How does travel change
as a result of that?
Separately, the company
has traditionally struggled
to police crime on its platform,
and that is expected to
get a lot more scrutiny
as the company sells its
shares to the public.
- [Narrator] Skeptics
wonder how long the company
can keep costs down and
stick to its core business.
And questions remain on whether the growth
in revenue and bookings is sustainable.
Or whether Airbnb is
simply the main beneficiary
of a battered hospitality industry.